[Music]
we're introducing a new segment tonight
one in which I play a judge isn't that
frightening we're calling it the arbiter
I forgot my gavel they didn't let me
check it on the overhead on United so I
don't have that the gavel I'll have it
back in Washington but as you can see
we're here in LA and currently one of
the hottest markets for marijuana the
city's lawmakers recently approved new
rules to regulate and legitimize the
cannabis industry ahead of January's
full legalization of recreational use in
the state of California
in tonight's arbiter segment attorney
Leo Tyrell thinks marijuana legalization
should be expanded even further than it
is and he joins with me in studio and in
DC horace cooper
the co-chair of project 21 a black
conservative leadership network takes
the opposing view okay gentlemen first
arbiter segment don't be nervous now
I won't all right Leo why should
marijuana use be legal and expanded your
honor very simply the federal rules are
outdated who's better to know than the
states let the state's decide you know
what marijuana should be decriminalized
it has been several states allow it to
be used legally for recreational use
because it's no longer the bulimic it
doesn't lead to harder crimes it's not
the situation where marijuana leads to
harder crimes or cocaine I'm submitting
to you that the states are in the better
position to regulate it take the
criminal element out of it it is the
best for the states to do it and I know
you agree with this let's not have
Washington in charge of what goes on in
every state
today's marijuana is not the marijuana
of the Woodstock day it's a much much
more potent much more powerful the THC
levels of marijuana smoked all those
years ago about 11% weaker on average
and Colorado is reporting 32% increase
in marijuana related traffic deaths from
2013 goes on and on increase in
marijuana related hospital stays
increase in marijuana related emergency
room visits that's what we need more of
an America
yes I read that same article you know
what even though let's deal with those
traffic accident even though they said
there was a higher use of people using
marijuana they're not saying that the
causation of the traffic limits were
caused by marijuana
I read that same exact artery all those
things are okay Horace you get your
opening statement nation it's not about
whether it's the federal government or
the state government the real question
is what's its impact on our local
communities and if you're coming up with
a program for making sure that our
working-class our communities of color
and many areas in the inner city just
get lost because they're left behind
because of the baleful effects of
marijuana legalization is the way to do
that every study shows that you see a
decline in academic performance a larger
number of people who participate
regularly are showing they are not
graduating from high school we are now
in a situation in America where for
graduate school stem says science
technology engineering and mechanical a
majority of the of those graduates are
foreigners because Americans aren't
available to step up to the plate we
should not be doing things that have a
clear correlation to failure in the
academic world as well as helping people
get on the track to self responsibility
and independence
Horace my follow-up to you is yeah I
think a lot of that is true however you
know alcohol causes huge problems we had
prohibition that didn't work so why not
try to take the criminal element out of
this and legalize it that way you can
have more educational campaigns and get
people on the same page so this isn't
about whether or not it is criminalized
the question is this glamorization
that's occurring and that is something
I've watched the pot cheerleaders like
leo go around saying what a wonderful
thing this is and our young people are
working-class people people who really
need to stay on track more employers
than ever in 2017 are drug testing what
does that mean you play around with this
and you prevent yourself from being able
to get that first good job and to earn
that opportunity for Independence he
makes an interesting argument about the
youth especially and in the studies now
being done by the psychiatric sources
and professors psychiatric disorders
bipolar disorder schizophrenia there is
increasing body of evidence that
indicates there is a correlation
especially in the developing mind so
with all the challenges Leo we have in
this country today
why would increasing the use of
marijuana which it does among young
people when you legalize it why would
that be good for society forget about
the semantic arguments about states
rights versus the federal government for
society given the medical evidence that
is mounting out there good question
Public Health Survey came out in
Colorado the state that you cited
earlier said that even though the
increased use of marijuana has done what
reduce the amount of opioid use that's a
significant factor although big issue in
this country about opium opioids the
marijuana reduction has made a
significant impact on that and for him
to sit there Laura and say that he
represents 21 states there are people
who want this big money want big weed is
how the billions and billions of dollars
the Gallup polls are very clear right
we'll see
because Colorado is suffering they're
getting a lot of money from the taxes on
marijuana but they're getting a lot of
problems too I'll give you the last word
and you can wrap up Horace and I'm gonna
give you my verdict the National
Institute for Health has done study
after study over the last decade in
which they show if you want to achieve
lower graduation rates if you want to
achieve lower performance levels on IQ
tests if you want to minimize people's
achievement marijuana is a great way to
accomplish that we are on a global stage
where the competition is severe and we
need to be getting every single American
geared to play their part
rather than doing things that distract
particularly in the inner city where we
have so many people that are suffering
the gaps from the last ten years of the
recession why would we add more shackles
to people why wouldn't we be trying to
encourage them I say my campaign for
math all right I have to give my ruling
now please both of you did a good job
and if I were a jury I might be hung
right now but I'm a judge this is this
is a bench trial it's a bench trial so
please PLEASE petitioner
Horace solver wins or as Cooper wins a
sorry that verdict goes to Horace but
again if it was a jury would be Hani
devoted it nice case presents reg you
should thank you I tried gentlemen you
both did a great job it's a really
important topic